[Applause]
on behalf of the faculty and staff of
the yale school of public health i
congratulate the members of the class of
2022
we are gathered to celebrate your
achievements and acknowledge this
graduation milestone
my colleagues and i welcome thank and
congratulate all
who played a critical role
in shaping the aspirations of all of our
graduates of the yale school of public
health and contributed to your success
these special people extend well beyond
yale
most notably including your parents or
guardians
your role models your siblings
your grandparents your extended family
and friends and for some of you your
spouses or partners and your children
we want to thank all of you who have
made this possible
make made possible the academic and life
journeys of our graduates so families
and friends of our graduates please
accept our heartfelt gratitude as we
pause to applaud your contributions to
our ysph graduates
[Applause]
now i address our mph graduates the past
three third 30 months have thrust our
school and our discipline of public
health into the spotlight
as we've striven to overcome this
historic pandemic threat
our schools faculty have highlighted the
social
inequities
that inhibit wellness in the most
vulnerable members of our population
these have included the
institutionalized elderly our frontline
workers
our healthcare workers in
in homes and long-term care settings in
clinics and hospitals
special efforts are needed for persons
with disabilities those with social
isolation
those with housing food or employment
insecurity
all these persons have been highlighted
in your studies and for many of you your
experiences as you studied here in new
haven
whether for covet 19 maternal mortality
or injuries death rates confirm racial
ethnic and economic disparities in both
risk and access to prevention and care
our
environmental scientists work on global
plastics toxins climate change and safe
air qualities in buildings our
epidemiologists biostatisticians and
modelers have worked to unearth the
causes and solutions of the covet 19
pandemic and to forecast its course as
they have done for tb
hiv vector-borne diseases and a host of
other tropical and local infections
our social and behavioral scientists
have refined health communications and
messaging for risk reduction and
wellness also examining the the
structural determinants of illness
our biologists have helped discover new
diagnostics new therapeutics and
vaccines unearth some of the origins of
disease pathogenesis
our policy and management faculty have
tackled a myriad of systemic flaws in
our health system
issues in tobacco and substance use and
vaccine policy to name but a few
our office of public health practice our
office of communications our office of
alumni and development have striven to
engage our various communities with new
vigor
helping transform our relevance to our
community our university
our alumni
our city of new haven our state and
region and even at national and
international levels
our emerging infections program and our
community alliance for research and
engagement that is a full partnership
with southern connecticut state
university deserve credit
that
for their massive community service
public health is more visible than ever
within society and we see the compelling
issues highlighted by media and policy
makers alike as never before
ysph students staff and faculty have
worked with nursing homes school
districts arts organizations yale alumni
other schools at yale and our partners
in low and middle income countries of
africa asia and latin asia and latin
america we've engaged our city and our
state as well as our governments and
institutions in other states including
new york rhode island even kentucky and
california
our strong community has been on the
forefront of yale's response to the
pandemic and continuing our momentum in
the many compelling themes of health
care reform
informatics and data sciences control of
chronic infectious diseases promoting
healthy mothers and children seeking
healthy aging paradigms
and addressing lgbtq health protecting
our environment and adapting to change
just to name a few
all of you graduating in 2022 have
attended ysbh in a historic moment for
our nation and our world
our community embodies boldness of
vision
persistence in the face of obstacles and
a commitment to public public education
and welfare in its health challenges
the public health workforce into which
most of you will enter works in
society's shadows
after all a patient assisted by a nurse
or a doctor is fully aware of the
benefits that might ensue
but a community kept safe by public
health insight and exertion may be quite
unaware of the hazards prevented or
mitigated in this year of 2022 you've
equipped yourselves for further study or
for immediate entry into the health
workforce with skills that the world
needs urgently
i have one hope for all of you that is
that your career
is such
that you wake up on a monday morning
to welcome the work week
for the ability to improve our society
and the world each and every working day
despite constraints due to covet 19 i
hope you leave with pride in your alma
mater
knowing that your studies in public
health happened at a truly historic time
of challenge
for our university society and global
community
when people ask me about the best part
of my deanship since 2017
i can say that the passion of our
students staff and faculty have
motivated and invigorated me to strive
to improve our school and our
disciplines meeting our future public
health leaders all of you
has enabled me to learn about your
accomplishments plans and aspirations
while our world has its immense
challenges i have a tremendous sense of
optimism
for the future of the field of public
health as we turn to the man we turn the
mantle of leadership over to you
our new generation
i speak on behalf of all the faculty and
staff when i say that we've been honored
to work with you guide your education
and learn from you
it now gives me great pleasure to
introduce
nuncini
has been chosen by uh
her and his peers her
her peers to deliver this year's
student address
nuncini's passion lies in
community-based trauma prevention
prior to her time at ysph she worked in
federal and state hiv
sti and tb prevention at the cdc
the oregon health authority and the in
utah department of health
as well
during her time at ysph
nuncini
has had the privilege of working on the
border identity stress team led by dr
skylar jackson to capture the
psychosocial experiences of individuals
who defy binary identification across
race gender and sexual orientation
she's also worked under the guidance of
dr kitra thompson as a qualitative
evaluator for the mom's partnership in
the elevate policy lab aimed at reducing
depressive symptoms and increasing
social and economic mobility for
low-income mothers in addition nuncini
has served on the board of yale's
emerging majority students association
and as a teaching fellow for the health
equity and social justice and lgbtq
population health
she looks forward to rejoining the
public health workforce postgraduate
graduation with the ultimate goal of
pursuing a doctorate in clinical or
counseling psychology
it is a an honor and an absolute delight
to invite you to the podium
uh
our 2022 student speaker
[Applause]
oh
thanks friends hi good afternoon
i can't believe this is actually
happening
amazing um so writing this graduation
speech felt actually it felt a lot like
graduate school me and my bestie google
against the world you can't exactly
google how to write a graduation speech
for a class that voluntarily studied
public health amidst a global pandemic
but for what it's worth i'll have you
know
that i did try
google said to find a powerful hook
something compelling
profound even
so i went to the next best place that i
knew wouldn't fail me
academic twitter
as expected i found myself in a rabbit
hole where i understood about 30 percent
of the vocabulary and even less of the
theory and based on this excellent
knowledge base and a vague
interpretation of others profundity here
i am in front of you all
the last speech i wrote began with a
quote from the dalai lama and this one's
from an organizational psychologist with
an impressive twitter feed so academia
has simply put broadened my horizons
adam grant wrote in two less than 280
characters
too many people spend their lives being
beautiful descendants instead of good
ancestors
the responsibility of each generation is
not to please their predecessors it's to
improve things for their offspring
this tweet actually reminded me of a
conversation i'd had with a supervisor
in my early years of public health who
advised that our role in this field was
to water a garden
consistently meticulously whether or not
we'd ever see it bloom
it's taken me many more years and
experiences with you all to realize that
our garden is literally the entire world
and that watering it comes in many
different forms from improving water
quality to increasing hygiene and
sanitation in conflict zones modeling
the impacts of major health policies
fundamentally restructuring our health
care systems designing sustainability
interventions to ameliorate climate
change analyzing and triangulating
millions of data points in an effort to
reduce transmission of disease and
finding new and creative ways to
motivate belief and behavior change
now more than ever it is clear that
public health impacts every system on
every corner of this earth
it's an exciting realization perhaps
coupled with big fat overwhelm
because our careers are often a labor of
love with the central goal of improving
life for those who may come after us
in a field so broad ever-changing and
now highly politicized what does it mean
to become a good ancestor
i'm not going to pretend like i know the
answer to this question or that i'm even
under the assumption that there is one
answer
after all one of the many things we've
learned in our time here at ysph is that
there are many truths and we will be
tasked with making room for them all
this program did however train many of
us as researchers who use observation
and conversation to make meaning and
consider solutions
so this is my earnest attempt without
sounding too much like a live off love
sign to give it my best shot
i do believe that a good ancestor is
driven by hope
when i began this program two years ago
my aunt a fellow public health
practitioner sent me an article called
hope cynicism and the stories we tell
ourselves
the article astutely remarked critical
thinking without hope is cynicism
hope without critical thinking is
naivety
this seemed at the time and even still
the perfect description of the public
health conundrum the call to hope is
really a call to retain a critical mind
and a soft heart
a critical mind to question everything
the methods the systems the
dissemination strategies the funding
mechanisms the theories the power
differentials the service delivery
a soft heart to remember why we do the
work
to see communities thrive to continue to
believe that change is possible
to give the gifts that we were given and
the gifts we've cultivated to create a
world that people actually want to live
in
here in public health hope isn't really
an option it is a necessity as
practitioners of public health
regardless of our concentration we
witness up close the very worst and the
very best that humanity has to offer
this reminds me of a text chain my
roommates and i sat after opening one of
our readings last spring the
epidemiology of human suffering amazing
we said what a warm and fuzzy field
many of us have seen patients turned
away because of lack of documentation
have contended with harmful policies
passed after decades of health advocacy
have witnessed public trust dwindle
throughout the coven 19
pandemic thwarting infection reduction
plans
still we continue to find hope through
many different avenues
hope comes in moments of curiosity in
moments we feel compelled to ask
questions about ourselves others and the
world around us
curiosity cultivates hope through
refusal of stagnation it insists there
must be more new options solutions
considerations
i hope you hold on to the power of
asking but why
hope comes in moments of love before
many of us knew each other we were just
tiny boxes on zoom screens smiling when
our roommates our partners our family
members said something from off screen
mouthing thank you to the person who
delivered us hot tea or laughing when
our pets entered our screen
pausing our attention to text our
friends back mid-lecture and creating
new relationships through zoom chat
love cultivates hope through remembering
that we are all whole people with full
lives i hope you continue to foster love
in your everyday life so you can
continue to extend love to the people
you serve
hope comes in moments of creativity when
we utilize a combination of imagination
and evidence-based practice or a new
strategy or a novel method
creativity cultivates hope through the
recognition the public health and
medical systems that we live within were
created by someone
why wouldn't we create the next
iteration
i hope you acknowledge your power as an
individual who will shape the future of
health
finally and in my unsolicited opinion
most importantly
hope comes in moments of heat of humor
humor i think is humanity's most
endearing survival tactic against
adversity we laugh about irony we laugh
hysterically when sleep deprived
something i'm sure none of us can relate
to
we laugh filled with adrenaline when we
exhibit bravery to speak truth to power
we laugh to connect with others to
release tension to try again and again
and again
i hope you find humor and connection to
keep you grounded
class of 2022 i don't know exactly what
it means to be a good ancestor but i do
know that you are all it your bright
minds your curiosity your ability to
hold the worst and the best the world
has to offer your wit and your humor
your critical minds and your soft hearts
we're entering the field of public
health at a time in history when our
hope is so desperately needed
and i do believe that we have some to
spare
i can't wait to see you out there making
your corner of the world a better place
to live in congratulations
[Applause]
thank you very much for those words
we're very grateful
it's now my privilege to introduce our
distinguished 2022 commencement speaker
dr heidi larson
she has to present to us from the world
economic forum in davos switzerland
because she was previously committed to
that event
professor heidi larson is the founding
director of the vaccine confidence
project and is professor of anthropology
risk and decision science at the london
school of hygiene and tropical medicine
she also holds a clinical professorship
at the university of washington and a
guest professorship at the university of
antwerp
in leuven
her
research focuses on the analysis of
social political factors
and managing risk and rumors
including digitally enabled
disinformation that can affect uptake of
health interventions her current
research is particularly focused on
issues around public cooperation during
emergencies
disease outbreak natural disasters
terrorism and conflict
professor larson previously headed
global immunization communication at
unicef
chaired gavis that's the global alliance
for vaccine immunization
advocacy task force
and served on the world health
organization
sage working group on vaccine hesitancy
she is author of a book called stuck
how vaccine rumors start and why they
don't go away
published in 2020 box for university
press
she's published widely on the drivers
and enablers of vaccine confidence
in 2021 she was awarded the edinboro
medal
in recognition of the role she has
played in recognizing the importance of
popular and widespread misunderstandings
of vaccines
bbc also named professor larson as one
of the 100 most influential women in the
world in 2021
dr larson joins us via cyberspace to
give our 2022 commencement addre address
to the mph class of 2022.
graduates faculty staff families and
friends it's a pleasure to introduce my
friend dr heidi larson
congratulations to all of you and i'm
i'm really sorry not to be with you in
person in new haven which i would have
loved to do
but i'm really grateful for the
opportunity to pre-record this address
and i chose to record it in the science
gallery here in bengaluru india
where i've been collaborating on in an
exhibit on contagion
and thought it was an appropriate
setting to be addressing you given their
inspirational efforts at making science
more engaging and accessible which is
foundational to public health
well what an important day this is it's
a milestone in your public health
careers it's actually the beginning the
commencement of your
learning
a different kind of learning a real
world learning and your leadership
you are some of the top uh public health
emerging leaders in the world and we're
all counting on you particularly after
this challenging couple years
you couldn't have had a more meaningful
time to earn your public health degree
in the context than in the context of
this current pandemic
you've also seen the real world reality
of public health outside of your
classrooms the swirl of politics of
publics and science all competing
sometimes and not cooperating while
trying to cooperate for attention
thankfully not all public health work is
in crisis and the best of public health
work helps to mitigate and prevent
extreme health outcomes in the context
of crisis and other settings and
emergencies
as we slowly and hopefully exit from
kovit
all eyes will be on building
preparedness and resilience in the face
of the next challenge whether it's a
serious disease outbreak or other events
such as natural disasters with their
health consequences
we will also need to address the many
health needs that were overlooked or
neglected because we had all eyes on
covet in these past couple years
some of these issues like even mental
health which were exacerbated made worse
during covet
i read a recent report that the pandemic
led to an additional 53 million cases of
depression in the world since cobit
we have a lot of work to do
as you choose your path after graduation
because public health embraces so many
different paths and the wonder of public
health and what i've loved being an
anthropologist working in public health
is the diversity of people i've worked
with my research group the vaccine
confidence project we have computer
scientists mathematical modelers
psychiatrists uh political scientists
epidemiologists vaccinologists and it's
the wonder of bringing these disciplines
together to ensure a more robust public
health
the biggest message i can give you when
i thought about what can i tell such a
brilliant group of graduates
after everything they've already learned
and one of the key messages i thought
was be open listen carefully this is the
beginning of learning
everyone around you as you enter into
your chosen role setting that you work
in
you'll be around people who each of them
has had a different experience these
last few years different challenges at
many levels
building the trust of those you work
with in your new setting will be crucial
to building trust listening in even
small ways to what they've been through
as a gesture of caring about the others
public trust has been a key issue
a lever a key lover of public
cooperation
in multiple around the multiple
restrictions and challenges we've had
during covid imposed on people for the
greater good
well what we as public health community
feel is the greater good wasn't
necessarily felt to be the greater good
locally or for some populations this has
been a challenge and a relationship
building time
countries where there was higher trust
in government faired much better than
those who didn't have as much trust in
government
we learned for instance in our global
vaccine confidence research that the
biggest predictor of covet vaccine
willingness was actually the perception
that government was handling the
pandemic well
the more confidence in the government
and how they were handling the pandemic
the more willingness to accept a vaccine
that was administered regulated and
sometimes required by government
i care passionately about public trust
and i'm hugely concerned about the
recent world economic forum
risk report which rated social cohesion
erosion
the ability of society to cooperate as
the global risk that worsened the most
dramatically during covet during the
pandemic
we would have thought we could have
thought and hoped that this would have
been a time to
embellish and strengthen social cohesion
but for whatever reason some of which
were very different in different
settings social cohesion and cooperation
didn't fare as well but they're
foundational to public health and this
will be absolutely crucial for you to
consider and think about how you can
contribute to rebuilding it in your work
ahead my second message besides be open
listen carefully is be ready for
surprises
one of the biggest learnings of the
pandemic has been the importance of
being responsive to changing
circumstances
uncertainty even changing science
evolving science that's been one of the
biggest challenges of the pandemic
keeping the public on board while the
information was changing
weighing what was the best available
evidence to make the best
decisions
recognizing that they may change
this is not the stuff of textbooks of
linear thinking about evidence to policy
multiple types of evidence and
situational awareness weigh into public
health decisions
knowing that again they may need to
change as situations evolve
the world did not stand together in a
kumbaya moment to get us through this
crazy crisis
the best successes when people ask me
where do you where did you see successes
the successes i saw were hyper local
they were local communities they were
giving and caring and mutual trust
settings that people pulled together and
understood each other's needs and also
the local health institutions local
governments local uh schools
understood their local community
local and locality mattered
because sometimes national leaders
global leaders that we would have
expected to line up together weren't
doing that as many pandemic preparedness
reports and commissions had anticipated
assumed or at least hoped
some leaders as you know will mislead
publics against away from the science
down the rabbit hole of conspiracy
in those settings when you can't have
the kind of confidence in a national
leader
localness and local leadership mayors
and others in local settings matter
tremendously religious leaders others
who the public trusts when there is so
much uncertainty
what has been particularly striking and
concerning about the nature and
scope of conspiracy rumors and
misinformation a topic i've spent a
tremendous amount of time with my
research group on this past couple years
is the level of aggression and anger
behind it there's been tremendous
emotion
uh during this pandemic and somehow
moving forward we're going to need to
come and and rebuild a more hopeful
optimistic rather than angry and anxious
public
it's not going to be easy but i'm i
think we're all counting on all of you
and your colleagues and other
universities uh to to work towards this
to be
good listeners and and trust builders
because we have a pretty fractured
environment but not everywhere we need
to build on the hope build on the
optimism build on the local trust
in the beginning of the pandemic
which was an early signal that we had
some challenges ahead i remember nearly
65 g towers were set on fire
others vandalized and workers and tower
people working there were harassed and i
was really
startled at how extreme the reactions
were and some of it was against people
not wanting to be told what to do how to
run their life and where
as vaccines became available and
increasingly required in many settings
as you know
they too have been a trigger of anger
and anxiety for some populations for
some people some of it was more anxiety
than anger it's uncertain it was so new
it was so quick
um and it amplified there was already
underlying trends of vaccine hesitancy
around the world but where we did well
it was a signal of trust building i've
i've always been struck i never expected
to be spending nearly 20 years of my
life working in the field of vaccine
confidence after many years working in
aids which was very much more bottom-up
than top-down as a as a pandemic
response
um
it's it's really been vaccine confidence
has such been such a window on people's
ability to cooperate
the last message which i've already
suggested and referred to is the to
never forget the emotions of publics and
they're more heightened than ever
publics are hugely heterogeneous they're
in there's no one public and in that
sense no one public health
um they're hugely heterogeneous with
multiple histories beliefs political
stances and emotions and all of these
factors have influenced their
willingness or not to cooperate for the
greater good
all of these factors matter as we work
together
for public health and better health
your effectiveness as public health
practitioners will be determined by your
alertness and sensitivity to these human
factors we have to embrace these factors
without losing the foundational science
behind them
while we can think of universal
principles for public health and perhaps
shared goals there will be varied
journals journeys to get there there is
no one universal best practice there are
many local best practices
be open
listen carefully
be open
listen carefully as you start your
journey and don't
don't stop listening it's the most
important thing
that i can think of
each time you listen it is a gesture of
caring
about
what the other person or people think
it's a trust builder
thank you
and again congratulations
thank you professor larson if you didn't
detect a british accent it's because
professor larson is from connecticut
we would like to now acknowledge our
student awards for this year's
commencement
we ask that all student award recipients
come to the stage to receive their award
when their name is called
we will be foregoing our handshakes in
deference to kovid but we can we're
allowed elbow bombs and whatever
so the first award is the dean's prize
for an outstanding mph thesis
and also the wilbur g downs outstanding
thesis prize in international health
the faculty and i commend all of you for
the excellence of your theses and
capstone projects
it's my great pleasure to acknowledge
the 2022 recipients of these two prizes
the dean's prize in the wilbur downs
prize
the recipient of the dean's prize for
outstanding
mph thesis is
are you ready
nuncini theo
[Applause]
receives this award for her thesis
she trusts us to love her you know using
a love ethic framework to explore faith
navigation and acceptance processes
among mormon mothers of lgbtq plus
individuals
the purpose of this study was to better
understand faith navigation
and lgbtq acceptance processes among
mothers in the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints in order to better
inform public health engagement with
highly religious parents of sexual and
gender minority children
nuncini please come to receive your
award
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
the recipient of the wilbur g downs
outstanding thesis prize in
international health is georgiana
estevez
georgia
georgiana receipt
[Applause]
could be a long afternoon just kidding
georgiana receives this award for her
thesis support or interference
relational influences on mother's
exclusive breastfeeding practices in
ghana
childhood malnutrition is a challenge
that needs to be understood as a global
health threat
exclusive breastfeeding is recognized as
the best practice to improve a child's
growth and cognitive development in the
first months of life
the world health organization recommends
exclusive breastfeeding until six months
mothers need family support to adhere to
exclusive breastfeeding practice
this study aimed to understand the
interpersonal level relationship
relational influences of fathers
grandmothers and other family members on
the mother child dyad adherence to
exclusive breastfeeding practices as
well as document community and societal
influences on exclusive breastfeeding
georgiana please come to receive your
award
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the henry j chauncey junior inspiration
award
and uh mr chauncey goes by his nickname
sam
so the sam chauncey inspiration award
was established in recognition of mr sam
chauncy who developed our program in
health management and fostered its close
collaboration with the yale school of
management
a former secretary of the university and
distinguished member of the yale and new
haven communities
sam has been both an agent of change and
a dear friend of ysph
this award was initiated by the health
management program class of 1999 and is
now supported by the school
it is given to the graduating health
management student who most exemplifies
innovation
integrity leadership and community
service
this year's recipient of the chauncey
award is victoria clark
[Applause]
who was also our flag bearer today vicky
came to ysph in 2020 with a bachelor of
arts in science and technology and
society
with a correlate sequence in in biology
from vassar college who's president came
from ysph
vicki deserves recognition not only for
her scholarly achievements at yale but
her impressive commitment to leadership
within the university and beyond
she has served as vice president of the
student association of the ysph board as
well as a health care management student
leader and peer mentor
she served as a student fellow in the
solomon center for health law and policy
in the yale law school
has served as a research assistant in
the connecticut emerging infections
program at ysph on a covet 19 vaccine
breakthrough study and has aided
multiple covet 19 pandemic related
projects at the school and at the state
level
vicki's ability to lead on multiple
fronts with
compassion kindness and strength has
inspired her peers as well as the
faculty and staff at ysph
it would not be an exaggeration to say
that vicky has become a part of the very
fabric of ysph in her short but
impactful time with us vicki please come
to receive your award
the low eleven award for excellence in
global health is awarded to a graduating
student whose work addresses health
promotion and global health the
recipient is selected based on their
internship experience and overall
academic record as well as their
academic achievement leadership and
community engagement
professor levin was a dear friend of
many a ysph alumnus on our faculty the
first head of the ysph international
health division
i'm very pleased to announce that the
low 11 award for excellence in global
health
has been awarded
to are you ready again georgina estevez
i'll i'll try i'll try that
pronunciation again georgiana stevis
georgiana came to ysph after working
with the dara institute in rio de
janeiro brazil for five years the dara
institute is a civil society
organization that works to promote
health and human development by
implementing and fostering an integrated
approach to fight poverty she's also a
registered nutritionist in brazil and
manages managed her private practice for
seven years until joining ysph in 2020.
since her arrival she's been a very
engaged student in the department of
social behavioral sciences
pursuing the global health concentration
as well as the maternal and child health
promotion track
through her passion for global health
and by leveraging her past experiences
she helped to facilitate a global health
signature internship with the dar
institute as a result a current global
health student will be working there
this summer
georgiana's academic performance in
global health has been exceptional
her thesis project is based on a highly
innovative quantity qualitative analysis
documenting the role that fathers can
play in supporting infant feeding and
other caregiving practices in ghana west
africa
her influential work is now informing
unicef and other agencies on how to
better design and implement effective
infant feeding and maternal child health
programs involving both adult and
teenage fathers
georgiana please come forward to receive
your award
[Music]
our annual ysph student award for
outstanding contributions in diversity
equity and inclusion dei for short
recognizes one or more graduating mph
students who have demonstrated a
significant contribution towards
creating and fostering a diverse and
inclusive community while at ysph
i'm pleased to announce a three-way tie
for this award
to lauren nicole cueto
ivy duong
and simile
let me try it
[Applause]
the
these
these three award recipients were
recognized for creating community and
implementing programs to help bring
students together they did significant
work in organizing efforts to increase a
sense of inclusion and belonging for
students at ysph through a range of
activities such as reporting supporting
recruitment efforts and organizing
student events and this wasn't an easy
year to be doing this with all the covet
constraints
students said quote they have created
such a welcoming and inclusive
environment by producing group events
that spoke to various groups of students
and being valuable resources on campus
for all students
lauren and ivy please come to receive
your award
okay here we go
[Applause]
we're now going to present the faculty
and fellow teaching awards acknowledge
our teaching awards for this year's
commencement
we ask that all teaching award
recipients come to the stage to receive
their award when their name is called
the ysph teaching fellow award
recognizes a student who demonstrates
outstanding performance as a teaching
fellow as we a tf as we call it and
promise as a future teacher
the recipient of the 2022 teaching
fellow award is thomas xiao a second
[Applause]
tom is a second year mph student in the
department of environmental health
sciences his nominator mike winter says
tom is a relentless bridge builder
from study parties
to friends meet meetups to mentorship
matchups tom organized countless
opportunities for friends to be made and
partnerships to be created and when
tom's semester and student reviews were
analyzed through a sentiment analysis
algorithm tom's score was the highest
score ever achieved by a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
highest score ever achieved by a
biostats teaching team member and nearly
double that of the course instructor
when
when prompted for criticisms of tom's
teaching
the students had two suggestions for tom
pick a different hour to host your
section
and number two don't tap the microphone
to test the room mike those were the
those are the two suggestions that he
got those were the only two
tom was beloved as you can tell and
these critiques are as harsh as it gets
students underscored that he's patient
understanding and determined to ensure
that students leave a section feeling
confident about what they have just
learned in eph 505. students also
expressed that tom is so awesome so
approachable so knowledgeable and
flexible
people say that about me don't they no
no no
no i guess i guess in fact they don't um
he was super helpful especially during
lab when many of us are learning to code
for the first time and i really
appreciated that he sent kind and
supportive notes to us throughout the
semester
tom finally please come to receive your
award
um
[Applause]
all right and we now turn to the faculty
the ysph distinguished student mentoring
award
recognizes a faculty member as a tea as
a leader in shaping the next generation
of public health professionals and one
who serves as a role model conveys
passion for public health has clear and
high expectations encourages students to
achieve their full potential is
sensitive to student needs and concerns
and makes extraordinary efforts to help
their students
candidates for this award are nominated
by graduating students and are selected
by a committee of both students and
faculty
this year the 2022 recipient of the
distinguished student mentor award is dr
idioma opara
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr opara who's been here about a year
is an assistant professor in the
department of social behavioral sciences
at our school of public health
she is the founder and director of the
substance abuse and sexual health lab
www.oparalab.org
her research interests focus on hiv aids
stis and substance abu use prevention
for urban youth
including racial and gender specific
prevention interventions for black girls
and community-based participatory
research with urban youth dr opara was
praised by students for being an
inspiration
they wrote in order to be an inspiring
mentor a professor must possess the
following qualities ability to provoke
original ideas dedication to their work
and their students
compassion and ability to instill
passion in their students dr opara
exemplifies all of these qualities
students also wrote dr opara is the
epitome of the positive impact
exceptional mentors can have on minority
students at elite institutions in gioma
my friend please come to receive your
award
[Applause]
11 months
the distinguished teaching award also
called teacher of the year
is the school's highest honor for its
faculty bestowed by its graduating
students
quality teaching is one of the most
important influences on a student's
experience at yale and this award
recognizes the recipient's leading role
in shaping the next generation of public
health professionals
the 2022 recipient of the distinguished
teaching award is professor david
paltiel in the department of health
policy and management
[Applause]
the
the objective that the objective that
guides dr palteil's scholarly activities
is to promote a reasoned approach to
decision making and resource allocation
in public health and medicine
trained in the field of operations
research dr paul teal designs and
implements policy models and
cost-effective analyses
cost-effectiveness analyses he has a
special interest expertise in hiv aids
and is published broadly on the cost
effectiveness of testing prevention
treatment and care
both in the united states and around the
world
david is praised by students for being
excited by quote
every student question answering them
with eagerness and appreciation for
students curiosity and creative critical
thinking
he created a sense of community among
his students and tfs by celebrating our
growth and recognizing the specific
contributions people made to the group's
learning
i am so fortunate to have known and been
influenced by dr palteal for all of over
a quarter century david please come
forward and receive your award
i forgot to mention david's important
work in covet 19 he pivoted his
his experience immediately and made
um
nationally influential contributions in
area but this is all for teaching this
is this is this is this is
this is not for that
so tom igeoma and david will have their
names inscribed on the awards wall on
the first floor teaching area in 60
college street
[Applause]
next we would like to acknowledge our
new faculty research awards just
initiated in recent years
by our
associate dean melinda irwin
our new faculty research awards resonate
recognize distinguished peer-reviewed
manuscripts the research awardees were
already highlighted in detail at our
ysph faculty meeting earlier this month
to highlight the public health impact of
their impressive research however i'd
like to share the awards with you
briefly
the early career investigate
investigator research award is given to
a ysph faculty appointment assistant
professor or associate research
scientist who was either the first or
last author on a given published
manuscript and we had a tie for this
award congratulations to dr kai chen for
his paper entitled role of
meteorological factors in the
transmission of sars kovi ii in the
united states he published this in
nature communications
and to dr fan lee
for in department of biostatistics for
his paper titled sample size
considerations for stepped wedge designs
with sub-clusters published in
biometrics
next is the investigator research award
which is presented to a ysph primary
faculty member of any track or rank
who was first or last author on the
published manuscript congratulations to
professor becca levy on the paper impact
of media based negative and positive age
stereotypes on older inf individuals
mental health published in the journals
of gerontology series b
and to dr michaela dinan on her paper
analysis of socio-demographic
clinical and genomic factors associated
with breast cancer mortality in the
linked surveillance epidemiology and end
results in medicaid medicare database
published in jama network open
our next award is the ysph covet 19
research award granted to a ysph faculty
member or group of ysph faculty whose
original research published in 2021
focused on covet 19.
congratulations to are you ready david
palatial and jason schwartz on their
paper assessing covet 19 prevention
strategies to permit the safe opening of
residential colleges in fall 2021
published in annals of internal medicine
and recognized as one of the highest
impact papers in that journal that year
and
doctors chantelle vogel professor albert
co professor sato mayor and dr nate
grubaugh on their paper the impact of
circulating sars cov2 variants on mrna
vaccine-induced immunity published in
nature
our next award is the ysph health equity
research award granted to a ysbh primary
faculty members exceptional health
equity related original research
published in 2021
congratulations to you dr youssef ransom
on his paper neighborhood social
cohesion and inequalities in covet 19
diagnostic diagnosis rates by area level
black
african american racial composition
published in the journal of urban health
and dr tarika mccall on her paper
development of a mobile app to support
self-management of anxiety and
depression in african-american women a
usability study published in jmir
formative research
the team research award is our final
research prize granted to a ysph team of
two or more primary faculty members with
one faculty member either being first or
last author congratulations to hannah
ehrlich amy bae dan weinberger josh
warren and
sunil parikh on their paper entitled
mapping partner drug resistance to guide
anti-malarial combination therapy
policies in sub-saharan africa published
in the proceedings of the national
academies of sciences and tyler shelby
xin zhao
donna spiegelman
loretta grow linda nikolai and luke
davis on their paper entitled lessons
learned from covet 19 contact tracing
during a public health emergency a
prospective implementation study
published in frontiers in public health
let's have a a round of applause for all
of these outstanding investigators
now is the moment you've all been
waiting for we take time to honor all of
our mph graduates can our graduates
please follow the direction of staff to
proceed to the stage when your name is
called please cross in front of the
podium to receive your diploma from me
we will forego handshakes given
continued sars kobe 2 viral transmission
the president uh the the the the the
yale school of public health alumni
association will be um
giving you your pin and welcoming you to
the um as
the aph
the ayaph the association of yale alumni
in public health of which you are now
members
and
it is my pleasure to introduce dr mayor
desai director of the advanced
professional program who will introduce
the candidates for the master of public
health degree in that program
[Applause]
foreign
i'll go ahead and read the names of
those who aren't here as well
friedrich leopold ackermann
[Applause]
richa athere
[Applause]
lawrence james castillo
[Applause]
liling
li ling chen
[Applause]
dante costa
[Applause]
cara rosalyn costanzo
[Applause]
kingsley crookshank
[Applause]
john paul singh diol
[Applause]
alison langford duran
[Applause]
oluwatomini
[Applause]
todd eulek
dan patrick gallagher
hello
frank masige willie cusaga
[Applause]
lee
[Applause]
christopher lawrence mclucas
[Applause]
gayatri teresa narendra
[Applause]
barbara
barbara awar odak
[Applause]
patel
[Applause]
ashok krishna
[Applause]
perumal matthew dylan pitchert
rock cj positano
[Applause]
richard robert rodriguez
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
h
[Applause]
richard smith
[Applause]
emily young
[Applause]
cushion
cushion zhang
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to introduce
professor
ma chair of the department of
biostatistics who will introduce
candidates for the master of public
health degree in that program
it's my great honor to introduce
candidates for mph in biostatistics
die chan
[Applause]
yan jin chen
[Applause]
yung tong chen
[Applause]
georgetown
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
young
[Applause]
children came
xiao fan leo
[Applause]
and hama
[Applause]
ulu pan
[Applause]
megan panera
[Applause]
railing too
[Applause]
eating one
[Applause]
[Music]
mailing can
now it's my pleasure to introduce our
doctor uh judy lichtman chair of the
department of chronic
ip disease epidemiology to introduce
candidates for mph in that department
thanks
it's a pleasure to be able to announce
our candidates
mahana alayami
[Applause]
nicole ann ancheta balosteros
[Applause]
ramirez
[Applause]
[Music]
lauren nicole cueto
[Applause]
holly nicole dowd
[Applause]
natalie sophie henning
[Applause]
catherine lewis hoe
[Applause]
dana norbert joseph
[Applause]
esther chuan kang
[Applause]
erica and fumiko kim
danielle marie klein
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
megan elizabeth lindsay
[Applause]
marie claire meadows
[Applause]
carlos mauricio mejia arbelize
[Applause]
marianne o'carr for
[Applause]
connor jesse peck
[Applause]
shemar samuel smalls
[Applause]
[Music]
jasmine yeshin soo
[Applause]
vani topkar
[Applause]
mae wong
[Applause]
rhian michelle wong
joseph williams
[Applause]
clara ming heiwang
[Applause]
and just reading one last name yoonfan
chang
it is now my pleasure to introduce dr
vasilis facilio chair of the department
of environmental health sciences who
will introduce the candidates for the
master of public health degree in that
program thank you
[Applause]
hello i'm honored to introduce our mph
candidates
giselle rita maria belia
[Applause]
[Music]
chewy
[Applause]
leora
nina fixel
[Applause]
emily elizabeth johnson
[Applause]
brady
keith roy
[Applause]
once again let's call tom sao
[Music]
phoenix rang chan
schwein
[Applause]
and
jaquen joe
[Applause]
thank you it's now my pleasure to call
dr linda nikolai interim chair of the
department of epidemiology and microbial
diseases will introduce the candidates
for the masters of public health degree
in that program
[Applause]
so it is my great pleasure to introduce
the following candidates
eliana sophia barbell
ann victoria lokalani basting
[Applause]
[Applause]
eli franklin biermann
kendall billig
[Applause]
lily
v
caruthers
[Music]
[Applause]
allison
catalano
[Applause]
backer hussein
[Applause]
robert tobias toby cook
[Applause]
lemanski
[Applause]
yeychi
lee
[Applause]
lynn
[Applause]
liu
[Applause]
rachel amanda loeb castones
[Applause]
caroline m mick williams
[Applause]
sarah yukari michaels
[Applause]
gwenevere van buskirk oliver
[Applause]
william thomas pelletiers
[Applause]
hannah peterson
[Applause]
thomas arthur grant quijano
[Applause]
alexander james robertson
[Applause]
hannah jane sprock
[Applause]
meng ting
[Applause]
mary martinovna tate
[Applause]
alice zhao
it's now my pleasure to introduce dr
howard forman director of the health
care management program who will
introduce the candidates for the masters
of public health degree in that program
[Applause]
it's my really distinct honor to
introduce the candidates for the masters
of public health degree
in the health care management program
hold on
we're back back
i'm the only one who didn't print my own
thing but you know
rahma ahmed
[Applause]
saron araya
[Applause]
daisy born
[Music]
[Applause]
victoria ashley clark
[Applause]
isha dave
[Applause]
michelle de la wassen baum
[Applause]
patrick dempsey
mila georgie
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
ivy duong
[Applause]
benjamin paul engler
[Applause]
sarah again
[Applause]
derek kenneth gautier
[Applause]
tyler john kellenberger
[Applause]
lee
[Applause]
lydia ginmar lee
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
tyler meow
[Applause]
hillary judith moss
[Applause]
phyllis nahutaba
[Applause]
benjamin thomas rosen
[Applause]
chen
[Applause]
kumar singh
[Applause]
kevin soon
[Applause]
melanie suzanne taub
[Applause]
xiao wang
[Applause]
we zhang
shaohan zhou
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to introduce dr
david paul teal professor in the
department of health policy who will
introduce the candidates for the master
of public health degree
for the master of public health and
health policy
christian abraham
priscilla badu secure
[Applause]
nicole
russell faria
shannon carter
jacob chen
[Applause]
rebecca gilman
julian johnson
[Applause]
sereja con daddy
[Applause]
gray
[Applause]
elaine lowden
[Applause]
laura
macon
megan malloy
anna marguerite
rayball
miranda rector
[Applause]
ian riley
[Applause]
when you already have one yale degree
why do you need another right
where was i
leah
leah robinson
[Applause]
[Music]
job ian
madeleine josephine sale
[Applause]
meg stellini
elise vanderwood
and isabelle sky
warner
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to call dr trace
kershaw chair of the department of
social and behavioral sciences who will
introduce the candidates for the master
of public degree in public health degree
in that program
[Applause]
all right sbs let's take this home
there we go
natalia
castianos gonzales
[Applause]
maya francis tracy dennis
[Applause]
let's wait
[Music]
nandini
milland dale
[Applause]
betty duran besella
[Applause]
georgiana estevez
[Applause]
elizabeth falacco
[Applause]
[Music]
fan
[Applause]
[Music]
paige farenkov
[Applause]
good job
hannah carolyn gorman
audrey ying and huang
[Applause]
emily
[Applause]
margaret cavendish kellogg
[Applause]
caroline alexandra mcgee
[Applause]
mojante
[Applause]
christine
pham
[Applause]
tonight pierce
[Applause]
jasmine
teresa rios
[Applause]
janet arena rohina
[Applause]
morico fujimoto rooks
bailey frida jean rue
[Applause]
[Music]
carla maxine pasquel c
[Applause]
kendall
naomi watanabe
[Applause]
julia michelle winchell
[Applause]
class of 2022
please stand all of you congratulations
to you all
you may be seated
thanks also to our program directors
representative aya ph our our chairs
our associate deans and especially frank
grosso and his extraordinary team
not only for this ceremony but for our
lunch
we're very grateful
i would like now to take a moment to
acknowledge our friends who aren't here
the ysph students receiving their phd
and master of science degrees
from the graduate school of arts and
sciences but they're really ours don't
you think
the 21 doctoral graduates and 33 ms
graduates are listed in your program
and they are recognized more fully
through yale's graduate school
commencement events which is where they
are now
please join me in recognizing all of
them with a round of applause
[Applause]
i immediately see that the dean's
closing remarks are a little too long
but don't worry
we'll we'll we'll be there we're seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel of
this extraordinary day
as we approach the end of our ceremony i
address you the ysph class of 2022. the
degrees you've been awarded today are a
testament to your commitment to
promoting wellness in communities
promoting health equity and alleviating
human suffering through the field of
public health
the faculty and i salute you for your
perseverance especially through the
travails of the covet 19 pandemic
we also wish to thank again
all the families and friends of the
graduates for joining us in this
celebration
all of you in attendance
families faculty and staff alike have
encouraged and inspired our students to
succeed in this exciting stage in their
career studies
yale university also wants to
acknowledge
that indigenous peoples and nations have
stewarded through generations the lands
and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship that exists between these
peoples and nations and this land
graduates you're moving on to your job
searches
your new jobs or your continuing
doctoral or professional studies at a
time of true crisis in our nation in the
world
rather than facts some would promote
lies and so-called alternative facts
rather than policy built on an evidence
base some would promote partisan
fictions for their own short-term gain
rather than strengthening fairness and
democracy some would roll back the clock
to restrict voting and biasing electoral
processes
america first was the motto of americans
who were pro-nazi in the 1930s america
first is now the motto for
pro-authoritarian
pro-aggression and racist and
anti-immigrant philosophies in the
nineteen in the twenty twenties
what then are scientists to do to help
guide policy makers and sincerely
motivated political leaders
i suggest three strategies first make
every effort to take your peer focused
research publications and your
professional presentations into a
community context
this is easier than ever with strong
social media and online publication
options
in this way you will democratize science
bringing lay descriptions of your work
to persons who will never read it in
nature jama or the american journal of
public health second seek to engage your
local online or print newspapers with
editorials with commentaries to
counteract misinformation that is
promulgated by anti-science forces
third try your very best to clarify
scientific and social misinformation in
your family and friendship groups your
local parent teachers associations and
governments and your fraternal
organizations and places of worship
listen to alternative points of view and
seek to find common ground but then
address misinformation
trust me with your public degree in hand
your legitimacy will be enhanced and you
can change hearts and minds
i would be remiss in not acknowledging
the acute suffering of our fellow human
beings
in such settings as rohingya or syrian
refugee camps in afghanistan and yemen
in the tigray region of ethiopia and
most notably in ukraine
less obvious is present is the global is
the growing climate change migration of
persons displaced by desertification
deforestation water and food shortages
and disturbed fisheries and agriculture
also less obvious that the continuing
crisis of sub-optimal nutrition and
sedentary lifestyles obstacles to
healthy aging
inequities in access to health care
ongoing harmful substance use
links to sub-optimal housing and health
systematic socioeconomic disadvantages
infectious threats and toxic
environmental exposures we can influence
all these challenges but we must make
our science accessible
ysph has made major strides towards
improving our communications to the
public and our policy makers we intend
to do much more i invite you to stay in
touch with us and partner with us and
the broader yale community including our
alumni
and
and towards we want to advocate towards
broad welfare of humanity
particularly those most vulnerable due
to systematic economic and housing
discrimination that might lead to food
deserts risk of injury and violence
educational disadvantages and so many
other health-linked social issues
the good news is that in our profession
we spend our professional lives working
towards mitigation of these legacies of
structural disadvantage health inequity
racial discrimination and extreme
economic disparities we strive for
improved health systems and functioning
we seek cleaner environments and
addressing the greenhouse gas emissions
crisis we identify and mitigate the
social determinants of disease
we seek to motivate and facilitate
healthful behaviors
the personal and community antecedents
of rising chronic diseases and ongoing
infectious disease threats are
characterized and then interventions are
designed and promulgated
importantly the methods of public health
in such disciplines as biostatistics
health data sciences health informatics
and implementation sciences are the
source of discovery and innovation
our global partnerships enable discovery
and capacity building in low and middle
income countries and our students are in
the center of so much of this work
we are privileged to be in the field of
public health
and your faculty are pleased to honor
you on this day of your achievements
finally thank you most sincerely to our
student affairs team that i mentioned a
moment ago they've worked so hard dean
grosso registrar's trade stacey tuttle
along aside my own colleagues in the
office of the dean
they've supported you for the past few
years
starting during the application process
and throughout your graduate experience
at yale
please join me in thanking them for
everything they've done throughout your
graduate training the yale school of
public health
please stay in touch with your old
teachers and the aya ph
our association for yale alumni in
public health in which you are now
subscribed let us know about the work
you do your successes and your
willingness to advise current students
mentor them to receive future summer
interns in the positions that you find
yourselves in and to contribute to the
annual annual alumni fund for their
scholarships in the future we will
always value your advice and your
support and a personal thank you to
students staff and faculty for their
support of my five-year tenure as your
dean
this concludes the ysph diploma ceremony
we ask that guests remain in their seats
until the representing faculty members
have departed
[Applause]
you